[Music]
this sure is a long way to go for
instant death hi everybody
okay chicken gonna fly chicken I didn't
think I was getting to death quite fast
enough so I added turbo boosters so I'd
be able to go farther fly higher smash
into it with your facehole right there
right there powers of the dunk
protect me from death I don't think that
works come on I need even more speed you
seem to be good you went a little okay
whatever well done hit your target hate
your talk favorite pose ever of anything
oh I seem to have lost my feet okay I
found another one I think it'd end well
come on baby
show me the noise there it is what does
it actually take to win this game
stop it what are you doing why because I
can I feeling there buddy you feeling
good I feel good hi bye Wow
you get out of here haven't I been
through enough no I should be fun
where did I go over there and over there
and over there and over there
let me see I'm flim-flam come on bring
on the Pam that ain't normal
bring on the Bam Bam no no you're such
an ass
I got turbo pads now you are gonna go
over that ramp you little douche don't
even try to stop that's right what a
relaxing day for death nice dog why'd
you go into it donk first go my little
friend walk right into it what the hell
happened maybe this one will get me in
there better nope Oh that bus is coming
back for me come on get in there I don't
even think my donk can protect me okay
no come on I believe in you you
beautiful bird maybe not
all right that's all for now I had a lot
of fun making this one so if you enjoyed
this video and you still want to see
more turbo dismount in the future leave
a like down below and let me know in the
comments thanks again everybody for
watching and I will see you in the next
video
[Music]